well business organizations ever given a
cautious thumbs up to the plans the
Institute of directors have many
businesses particularly manufacturers
and welcomed the decision but warned
many questions remain unanswered
meanwhile the CBI has been stronger in
its support for Labour's proposal and
its director-general Carolyn Fairburn
joins me now Carolyn welcome to you what
you wanted to hear today well good
evening in yes I think this is a thumbs
up for Labour's position taken today
it's about barrier free trade in Europe
and that matters hugely for
manufacturers it's about making trade
easy jobs dependent on that particularly
Midlands the north but the second point
is Northern Ireland we don't see a
solution to Northern Ireland to prevent
a hard border returning without a
customs union so yes a good step forward
today the problem is though that a lot
of what Jeremy Corbyn said was very
heavily caveated for example he said
he'd only welcome membership of a
customs union if the UK could have
influence over its policies that's never
gonna happen the EU will never wear that
will they well I think it's very
interesting we can learn a lot from
other customs union so there is one with
turkey at the moment Turkey it's not a
member of the EU but is a member of the
customs union and we think it's right to
be doing trying to do better than turkey
we should be alongside the European
Union in trade negotiations so that is
going to be part of what we need to to
seek but the core points about barrier
free trade I think is the main one but
is any of what Jeremy Corbyn said today
remotely deliverable under those terms
well what's really interesting is that a
customs union is of benefit on both
sides so I talked to manufacturers in
Germany who equally vita' the points
made by Airbus would be reflected by BMW
and know German and French firms as well
so the mutual interest here is really
strong so I think yes I think we should
be going for a deal that works for for
businesses and for our trade
negotiations of course the the the
brexit ears would argue that being in a
customs union precludes the ability to
negotiate external trade deals elsewhere
well we don't really see it like that
like that and nor do and businesses
don't see it like that we can do both
it's very interesting in China the
opportunities to build our trade that
right now are huge in Germany already
exports five times more than the UK to
Germany I was there
in January and we signed nine billion
pounds of trade deals they did not need
a free-trade agreement so I think we
should be trying to do both a customs
arrangement with the European Union and
building global trade around the world
Jeremy Corbyn has been a long-standing
critic of the EU he voted against
membership back in 1975 do you think
this is a genuine conversion well I
think the important point here is that
this is a jobs first proposal in
something which businesses have been
calling for it creates easy trade in
Europe and you know I think that labor
are talking about jobs first and that is
that is a very good thing I mean there
are parts of their manifesto and their
plans which have a sting in their tail
which I think business are very
concerned about but on this point I
think this is about putting jobs first
but do you think they could have gone
further and argued to remain in the
single markets because of course the
customs union only really benefits
manufacturers it's single market
membership that would apply right across
the piece for the services sector I
think that's absolutely right and it's
not about membership a single market as
much as about protecting benefits of
single market and that has to sit
alongside customs union so the two need
to be seen in parallel and we I think as
the CBI are arguing for that as well so
who's got to the point Carolyn where the
CBI trusts labour more than it does the
government on brexit right there I think
it's a really important thing this isn't
about party politics you know businesses
in the West Midlands who are exporting
to Europe it's not about party politics
for them it's about can they maintain
their operations here easy and free
trade so I think this this is about
what's right and easy and practical for
the post brexit world all right Carolyn
Fairburn from the CBI good to see you
Sarah thanks for joining me